no essentially no no I don't want to be
like horribly abrasive like there's
context right so you know
um like I'm in my first trimester and
wrapping it up and you know I've been
very tight and exhausted and so my
husband will go and he'll make a meal
for me or he'll like get a meal for me
and things like that it's very
contextual but no I I don't want a yes
man and a lot of women have had
experiences with Yes Men I mean we know
that women have leverage I'm sure
Pearl's had experiences with yes men too
it's not fun it's not cute and you know
that's but that's the thing it's like
it's very interesting for men because if
we ask for something else we say
something we actually mean it you know I
mean like generally men will be like
okay this this and that's what I want
remember like this this this is he gonna
do it yeah
I mean like we don't actually it's
partially like unconscious I'm just
smart enough and aware enough to tell
when I'm doing it I was just thinking
though I can imagine all the all the
haters in the chat be like sort of like
oh my God like like it's it's women
actually sitting and complaining about
guys doing things that are nice for them
oh my God like he was too nice oh he
can a girl be too nice to you yes
[Laughter]
I think they can't I think they can yeah
okay explain no I think they can because
it's like what we were saying earlier I
think I think actually
um if a girl is too into you and she
does too much for you I think that can
be a little bit jarring as well I think
actually the genders have probably
actually not that dissimilar in image
there's female stems but that's just
because you're overshooting your shot
like you need to take a Donna Peg you
need to you know I think I think it's
because men I think a lot of the time
men are not used to
they're not used to having women like
really like a lot of men are not used to
having women like really loving them I
think that might you know what I mean
yeah I think that's what it is it's like
because we're used to kind of doing the
pursuing and doing all the kind of all
this kind of stuff like when a woman
says oh my God you're amazing oh my God
I can't get enough you're like is this
woman is she is she lying like can I
have an example where a girl did too
much
well I was I mean I was dating a girl a
while back and it was just like and was
it her looks was she not no no no she
was really she was she was very cute
um and but she was just it felt like she
couldn't do enough I mean she'd always
make me breakfast in the morning and she
and then she'd make me and I don't even
eat breakfast so that was kind of
annoying I'm like listen I don't really
eat breakfast I like to just have a
coffee and then she comes oh and she
bring this you know the porridge and
it's piled up with fruits then she's
like oh can I get you somebody else can
I get you can I use some eggs can I do
some eggs right no no no you know it's
too much too much and I mean again you
know was it too much too soon though
how young you were not not really I mean
we've been dating for for a while it
just I think I think maybe it's partly
personal to me because I think there's
an element of me I'm quite independent
independent being like too closeted by
people it makes me feel a bit so that
might just be a personal preference to
me I think you're right what what um
what culture was she from was she
Western was she Eastern European she was
actually she's actually used in European
oh okay because I feel like that's
uncommon for those women that's the way
they act though I mean uh
um I'm from Rome but even in Rome
because in my generation uh A girl's got
to be virgin at least back in the days
for the marriage on my first 15 years
old I understand if I wanna hook with
the girl my age is basically impossible
and obviously living a room is full of
tourists and uh but the first relation I
had with tourist care which at the time
they have slightly longer early day but
we look at about in a week and 15 days I
have to find a new a new partner or my
teenager right that's why I started
learning the language I used to be
taking the piece about it because I
speak Italian English Italian French
Italian Spanish right and that's why so
but even when I came to London one thing
I understand forget about the London
again because they're too busy they got
the standard so they want to interact
with you because the moment the CEO is
Italian is like that they don't even
know you so again I started to went with
people living in London like me so a lot
of East European a lot of Italian
American as well a lot of Latin American
and and that's the way it is
um and the more uh let's say
accommodating in a relationship they got
some kind of I don't want to say
servitude but they do the kind more of
open-minded in central things yeah
obviously if they become too sweet you
start to think oh well maybe they want
to get married and and that's for a lot
of guys do you not want to get married
I'm 51. I I've been living a few girl
for some time but not for long I mean
the longest relationship I have was
three years really right and uh I I just
do things the No Ordinary for people you
know do you think that's part of the
loneliness though because people don't
want to get married now it's not why I
don't want to get married it's just uh
I'm doing different things I'm gonna do
a nine to five job uh I'm not a
financial virus or I'm working as a
postman uh I do freelance job through
security show business then as I say to
you I've been very sick I tried to talk
so I'm not getting stressed in a
relationship if the same Department it's
not On My Level or she doesn't
understand that my dear you know you
want to live your life from it's okay go
yeah okay I was going to read yeah go
and go for it okay guys thank you so
much for these super chats I'm gonna
read a couple
um actually I'm gonna read all of them
hold on okay 90 free-toe pet
um the difference in checking is men
aren't abusive with it um stop and think
it's complicated says women make it hard
for men to have sex with them Pearl
quotes one out of three men one out of
three men haven't had sex in the past
year and most men are virgins before 30.
I didn't say most if you're gonna quote
me
one out of three um with this
information in mind do you think most
boys and men develop corn addictions if
sex is hard to get think about this
Dustin Denton um 500 Super Chat
lonely lonely lonely makes matchmakers
rich 8K for 24 matches or I'm on a
second company now for 5K 90 free-toe
pet in the past we had shame now only
the oppressors are ashamed that's the
real issue men live in logic and Truth
we can't help and but call out female
lies
um
I'm morphess um audio has no bass and
the volume is low
um Seth blader I agree that women only
get a chance to experience loneliness or
I agree that women don't get a chance to
experience loneliness until they're much
older they appear to only experience it
when their long-term partner dies or
their vast their last friend dies
a Kenmore it's not loneliness but lack
of purpose for men most men conflate
having a woman as a sense of purpose
Captain Cisco pearly have you heard of
the legendary YouTuber name from South
North Carolina Edward Anderson actually
haven't heard of him
um Terrell Clark her intelligence
doesn't affect my income um thank you
I'm Kirsten Eskimo
um
yeah that's all of them go ahead Sarah
if you have another video you wanted to
share yeah I have another video
um as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible